중계 수수료를 좀 이렇게 비트코인으로
받는 제도를 좀 하려고
합니다네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다
제가 오늘 비트코인으로 15억번
공무원 앞구정 현대 아파트를 사러
간다라는 기사를 보고 느낀 점이
있어서 좀 영상을 찍게 되는데
커뮤니티에 좀 올라온 글이에요 그래서
공무원 분이 비트코인을 투자해서
15억을 번 그런 수익 인증
커뮤니티에 좀 올렸습니다 총 평가
금액이 한 35억 정도 되더라고요
그래서 요거 가지고 이제 현대
아파트를 사러 간다라는 글을 가지고
올렸는데 지금 난리가 나왔습니다
그래서 아마 많은 분들이 보셨을 것
같은데 저는 이걸 보면서 느낀게
뭐냐면 앞으로 비트코인 투자자분들
그니까 이제 수익을 버신 분들이 이런
압구정 현대라는 우리나라에서 누구나
다 살 만한 사고 싶은 그런 집들을
많이 살 거 같아요 그게 이제
2021년도에 그때 불장 때 코인으로
돈 보셨던 분들이 실제로 많이
샀거든요 구정 현대도 사고 강남의
빌딩도 사고 그래서 이번에 불장 때도
코인으로 돈 버신 분들이 구정
현대라는 뭐 지금 다 지어는 뭐
원베일리든지 이런 상징적인 부동산에
많이 투자할 가능성이 저는 좀 크다고
봅니다 그분들이 이제 투자를 하면서
주요 지역에 있는 부동산들은 한 번
더 좀 오를 거라고 좀 조심스럽게
예상을 하고 그리고 올해 어찌됐든
1월에 이제 미국에서 이제 etf
승인이 되고 그리고 이제 미국은 거의
약간 정식 자산 제도권 안에 좀
들어왔잖아요 근데 우리나라는
아직까지는 좀 제도권에 들어오진
않았지만 제가 봤을 때 시간이 좀
지나면은 들어올 거 같거든요
비트코인도 이제 좀 자산으로
인정받으면 비트코인으로 부동산 사는
시대도 곧 올 거 같아요 그래서 저는
좀 생각하는게 앞으로 이제 중계하고
나서 이제 중계 수수료를 좀 이렇게
비트코인으로 받는 제도를 좀 하려고
합니다 이게 시대 변화에 따라서
코인으로 돈 보셨던 분들이 수수료나
이런 것도 코인 으로 이렇게 할 수
있게끔 계획하고 있어요 아마 조만간에
할 거 같습니다 아마 국내 최초로
중계 수수료를 비트코인으로 받는
회사가 되지 않을까네 렇게 생각을
합니다 저는
비트코인을 강남 부동산이라고 예를
들어요이 비트코인은 공급의 제한이
있습니다 그래서 2,100만 개 딱
공급이 한정돼 있어요 누가 더 찍어낼
수도 없고 주식처럼 증자를 수도 없고
그냥 그 딱 2,100만 개만 딱
있는 겁니다 공급은 한정돼 있는데
수요가 많으면 가격 오를 수밖에
없거든요 그래서 강남부동산 같은
경우에는 제가 왜 비트코인 갔냐고
말씀드리면 공급의 제한이 있잖아
그니까 저희가 땅을 눌릴 순 없잖아요
공급은 한정돼 있는데 살려는 사람이
많잖아요 그러면서 이제 좀 가격이
계속 오르는 겁니다 돈의 가치는
하락하고 달러도 계속 찍어 내잖아요
지금 그 미국 부채가 너무 높아요
국방비가 거의 약간 천문학적 금액인데
국방비를 넘었다는 기사도 좀 보긴 했
그래서 그만큼 이자를 되게 많이 내야
돼요 부채가 많아서 그 이자를 내려면
사실 돈을 찍어낼 수밖에 없거든요
그래서 달러도 아마 더 찍어낼 거
같고 돈은 계속 찍어낼 수밖에
없습니다 그래서 저는 좀 고객
분들한테 많이 말씀드리는게 가치가
계속 하락하는 돈을 가지고 있는
거보다는 공급이 딱 제한돼 있는
자산으로 좀 바꿔 놓으라 그러거든요
공급에 제한돼 있는 거 지금 5억이
5년 전 5억이 10년 전 5억은 또
다릅니다 그래서 빌딩 가격이 오르는게
물론 이제 임대 수익이나 뭐 그런 것
때문에도 오르기도 하지만 인플레이션
때문에 오르는 거예요 돈의 가치가
떨어지니까 공급에 좀 제한되어 있고
사람들이 많은 많이 찾는 자산에 돈을
넣으셔야 됩니다 투자를 그렇게 하셔야
돼요 그래서 제가 계속 이제 주요
지역에 사라고 하는 이유가 바로
그거예요 저는 계속 얘기했어
유튜브에서 지금 뭐 몇 번을 얘기한지
모르겠지만 살 거면 주요 지역만
사는게 제일 안전하고 제일 좋습니다
그래서 이분들 계속 코인만 할 수
없어요이 돈을 일정 부분을 빼서 집도
사고 빌딩도 사고 할 겁니다 어떤
식으로 좀 살지도 여러분들 생각해
보시면 좋을 거 같아요 좀 정리를
해보자면 비트코인이 이제 가격이 이제
1억 넘었죠 1억이 넘으면서
비트코인으로 수익 번 사람들이
많아졌고 근데이 사람들이 돈을 벌면
코인만 가지고 있는게 아니라 다른
자산에 투자를 하는데 근데 아마 이제
첫 번째 우선 순위가 부동산을 많이
살 겁니다 그리고 그중에 집을 많이
살 거 같고 압구정 현대라는 이런
주요 부동산들 어 그런 거에 투자를
많이 할 거고 플러스 이런 강남
빌딩이나 뭐 성수동 빌딩이나 한남동
빌딩이나 뭐 이런 주요 지역에 있는
빌딩들을 사려고 할 겁니다 그래서
그런 지역에 있는 빌딩들은 제가 봤을
때 가격이 더 오를 거 같아요
여러분들은 공급이 제한되어 있고
수요가 많은데 어 그런데 부동산을
투자해야 안정적으로 내 자산을 지킬
수 있습니다 제가 말씀드렸던 그런
투자의 기본 원칙을 좀 지키셨으면
좋겠습니다 부동산은 무조건 입지입니다
그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요
다음 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다